[Music]
all right since we got an article that's
about some sneaker news we got Norman in
the house to
Norman resident JK sneaker expert here
something happened in Australia where a
dude spent 30,000 how much did he spend
on these shoes I think it was 20,000 us
and like 30,000 UK wow 30k on a pair of
shoes are they super rare the Yeezys did
buy couple rare shoes and then yeah but
was it one pair that was
20K yeah multiple pairs but finds out
that they're fakes oh oh those
Chinese but the catch here is that after
they determine that they were fakes the
police said there's nothing you can do
about it and really here's why why cuz
Aussies don't care uh I think he bought
it in the UK I bought it from someone in
the UK I don't know what the law is out
there but I guess cuz the kids 17 years
old at the time um and they couldn't do
anything cuz he's underage so he's like
protected by the law from that so you
can do cons if you're 17 in the UK I
guess dude what is he Chinese is Joe's
important question you know he Chinese
well the Chinese made it you know he is
I don't know any other group that can
make fakes as good as Chinese you guys
been on
teu teu got the fakies my boy you know
what they're not even actually fakes so
one of the best ways that they make it
is let's say there's a Nike Factory
right what they'll do is they'll create
a night shift train them how to make it
exactly the same way same Factory so
let's say Nike contracts them to make
like a th000 [__] shoes right then at
night they make a th000 more same
materials same Factory everything now
you have 2,000 of mhm and then and then
that one is just sold in the black
market but it's the same shoe say so
who's the scam is it Nike for marking it
up would you pay 30k or 10K or 20K for
these how much are those worth what the
font that's not even the right Dior
worth honestly those might be 12 to 15K
wow would you pay that yeah but the so I
had the lows of that and I paid 4 grand
for that there you go that's a value
invest it was for my wedding you wore it
I didn't cuz it didn't look good with
the outfit so I just sold them for more
how much what did you make five grand so
I made a grand okay okay but that's why
people are getting them though it's like
you either display it or they're like
Collectibles or but see my uncle Mark if
he heard that those shoes are worth 15K
and then he bought them for five he
would only take 15K for them so you're
not that good of
invest so you said that um this scam has
happened happen to you before as a
sneaker reseller uh it kind of happens
to everybody especially if you're new
really yeah cuz you don't know how
certain people are scammers have a
certain way of getting you oh cuz you're
buying like person to person not going
on like a site or whatever no no no I'm
buying like just like an offer up or
something from someone or Craigslist
something so so do they show you the
real shoe on pictures and then send you
the fakes uh I usually buy in person
unless I know the guy now and when you
show up in person you can't tell that
it's fake hard to tell yeah yeah cuz it
comes from the same Factory yeah
especially now it's a lot harder cuz
they used to use a black light to scan
it and you can see like markings but now
you can't even see the markings
sometimes and just everything is almost
the same and there's just like one
little thing that's off and you might
miss it it's the same Factory to be fair
though if you can't tell come on what's
real and what's not it's not like it's
not like you're trying to put your hand
through and it's a [__] hologram you
know what I mean able to tell the
difference you know those those sneaker
guys like at cool kicks that can slap it
and by the the sound they know it's real
or fake Is that real that's for the gram
huh it's kind of real uh there's
material difference is like very minimal
but it's hard to tell unless you've done
it often they make mistakes like if it
sounds Hollow or if it sounds like a
what is it like a watermelon or
something they have like a weird fruit a
fruit scale yeah I I usually I check for
like stitching marks and like and I
inside the shoe because that's the
harder part that people don't really
check but I mean even me like I don't
know it perfectly so you still get got
sometimes I've gotten got yeah and then
I would just sell it as a fake but I
just have to tell them it's fake and you
get buyers that want fake yeah but I
lose money on that though what if you
told them it's real and you got caught
is that
fraud I guess but but won't you get in
trouble for selling fake shoes a lot of
people do it and then they just
disappear so like I I know a lot of
people in the beginning they sold like
hundreds of thousands dollars shoes of
fakes to a whole bunch of people and
then they just disappear they just move
to a different country or if it's like a
really big thing they'll move to a
different country or some people just
disappear and then you can't find them
dude congratulations to them they they
did it they made it that's amazing
that's the best con what about those
people that deliberately Design shoes
that look like knockoff dunks but
there's like a little difference in the
logo you know those uh like like Lauren
Warren Lotus or something like that
where they have like the Nike swo ons
but like om Omie and a Hellcat like that
guy it'll just be like very close to a
dunk but like it's meant to look like a
bootleg a lot of them are getting sued
by Nike so crack it down on him now yeah
can't be messing around got it is there
like a shoe task force out there there
should be one oh yeah STC shoes task
force I think that's good there's like
a there'ss and stuff to like check them
but even the app sometimes get it wrong
how do you become how do you become a
shoe expert guy like a shoe connoisseur
like a shoeman like how did you how did
you start off I I just had a I had a
friend that was into shoes or he he had
the back dooring and all that stuff so
then he kind of told me about it CU I
was like everybody else like damn this
is hard to get I forget it oh so just
start off as a hobby yeah and then a
close friend of mine had a he had a
connection and I was like okay might as
well join him it is crazy how like
authentic even fake stuff is cuz my dad
he used to work at UH Commerce Casino
you know when people have like bad beats
or whatever they want to get back in so
one of the dudes he was like [__] I need
to get back in and then so he comes to
my dad and he goes hey like can I sell
my sell you my RO my dad's like oh sure
so he takes a look at it and he's like
dude this sh looks like really real so
he just bought off them for I think like
2 Grand and it was supposed to be worth
like 5 grand and then so my dad's
rocking it he showed me oh I got this
from this guy I'm okay cool and then the
one day that the battery died he takes
it in when they open it then they're
like oh this is fake Dam and then he's
like [__] cuz Rolex don't have batteries
but you can't even tell that it's uh
that it was that yeah you can't even
tell that it was fake um until they
opened it and then when he so he ended
up getting a real one and he put him
side by side and you just can't even
[__] they feel the same the weight
everything and it's just crazy W
sometimes the fix are actually better
than the real on really I'm going to get
a fake one D got a couple fake ones I'm
like this is so much better than my real
one how much are fake how much are like
fake Ries usually are they still like a
couple Grand like a good one get for
like2 $300 there's tears there's tears
you can get like a shitty fake one you
get like a level two fake one then you
can get the one that's like you can't
tell the difference give me all the fake
[__] I don't care you don't care I don't
I got bro I have pair of fake Yeezys and
I brag to people and I'm like yeah I got
them off teu for $112 but you want to
know why it's bad why you might get like
held up over it that's really embarrass
don't worry guys it's fake like TSA or
some [__] no what if you get jacked off
the street you got much then it was 200
bucks yeah at least you didn't lose
2,000 that's you know what's even worse
you get held up and they're real yeah
correct I don't see a downside butd you
just gave us like a good argument for us
no way why would you want to enter the
culture of Rolex owning if your
lifestyle doesn't rol no I don't want to
be in the culture how dare you dude I I
learned from my Chinese fake conour
people that when it comes to certain
things fake is always better than real
like for example um purses or bags or St
luxury goods like that you don't really
want fake because those are like
hand-me-downs those are like a family a
so they're actually things that can also
grow in value based off of culture style
whatever right but like why the [__] are
you paying like $600 for a Balenciaga
like t-shirt
nobody gives a [__] about the fake
clothes that's that's a [__]
scam it's a white T-shirt you IDI get
the [__] yeah exactly except for the W
sweater guy but at what but at what
price level does it become that because
like well the thing is it's always it's
always a perception thing right because
like nobody else is going to know and if
you're in that crowd too people don't
hella question you but if you're rocking
like a real Lou bag and you have a fake
Louis t-shirt that's fine cuz you
already have the access that makes
everything like in a sense real like the
clothing nobody's going to give a [__]
about the actual clothing you know what
I'm saying that sounds how much are
Gucci slides do you know Norman that
trend is gone Dam oh damn why you guys
to say like that Norman you don't know
sh that was our fashion guy until just
now cuz I was saying I was like you
don't you don't buy the real Gucci
slides cuz that's [__] dumb they're
probably too expensive that was my point
but now they're not even in they're not
capable being a hand me down you go real
what's the trend that is going on right
now not this one right Gucci belts it's
not that one I'm sorry that's not a good
shoe right I mean oh my God objectively
that's not a oh yeah yeah it's not it's
a piece of
[__] now we know he's an expert at least
so now we know were you able to get one
of those uh I didn't know when they
released I knew about them but I didn't
know when they released yeah nobody
nobody did that's what makes them a
rarity it's like a [__] Charizard
hologram oh really yeah is it we'll see
how that how that ages how is that
$1,000 hoodie that nobody's going to buy
Steve I get so far I can get one I can
get pair of these for 80 bucks where's
your nft pfp this was $300 Dude Looks
like it you could you could probably
easily move one of those if you had it
in your stock yeah I don't know if I
have the market for that I'm sorry but I
really don't you don't have to apologize
do hey he he can sell fake shoes easier
than he can sell that [__] not going to
lie
probably I
like prob makes you feel good to try and
jump on the bandwagon of dissing like a
sick ass collab with Tinker Hatfield who
I think you know who he is he does like
the Jordan stuff yeah yeah I think you
might
know no that's dope no dude you're real
you're a
real wait what was the thing that was
happening recently where on a actual
website they were selling fake shoes and
it was like Nike oh uh the Nike
refurbished what is the Nike refurbished
thing uh so they had their own Nike had
their own refurbished thing where they
try to sell their used shoes um or like
any used shoes that they got or like
return shoes and I guess people were
buying real ones and then just returning
fakes oh and so they don't spend any
money basically and they'll make all the
profit on the shoe that damn and then
Nike was selling it refurbished cuz I
don't think they like legit check
everything Nike doesn't have a guy that
can check it better than the guy at cool
kicks Melrose scary but they just they
probably just look see I still
congratulate the the middleman who's
[__] doing that like that's a win
that's what a lot of people think that's
because people ordering from refurbish
and getting fakes they're trying to sell
it f damn from an actual Nike sanction
so they they shut it down like a month
after that came out but then again same
thing though right if Nike can't [__]
tell that it's fake is it fake I already
told you guys how they do it it's at the
same Factory honestly I think it is they
they probably have a guy that you don't
need to think I had Chinese people that
own factories that told me to [__] it's
the same [__] I buyle [__] all the time
like NFL jerseys dude they use the same
exact Factory they just turn it on at
night that's what that's what I heard
yep you heard it from me they I heard
from you they make the Nike logo like a
little bit bigger that's what they did
on fake I TR I bought one I know I got a
fake Lebron James jersey when SLO and
Swami was around they had some pretty
bad fakes you know that's what I miss
old I missed the blatantly fake in
Chinatown I remember dudes becoming to
school with the five stripe Adia yeah
Adas yeah where the second D was an a
yeah I like those man it's clear I miss
I miss
Spiderman Spider-Man was one of my
favorite SP Spiderman was everywhere the
swap me toys they're the best dude she
man that's the best dude she big old
trap yeah shean Wonderman that was
another one that was good who's
Wonderman he's like a Superman knockoff
yeah it's like wannabe Superman it's not
wannabe Wonder
Woman was it like a Wonder Years toy
Spider Guy they didn't sell spider there
was Spider Guy didn't
s there was Catman there was man it was
really good so what tell us again what
is the hottest thing that you're trying
to find in the shoe game right now I'm
slowly getting out of it really why too
toxic bowling's picking back up it's
kind of like stocks right now
everything's just down oh no one's
buying and trading these ones that I'm
wearing right now I got them for like
400 back then and I was cheap now it's
like 200 brand new maybe brand new so
it's a good time to buy huh it it's a
good time to buy and my shoe doesn't
have a market huh you want anything
that it doesn't that's literally what he
said he said it doesn't have Market the
whole Market's down
buddy [__] is like all asset classes are
coming down I wonder if watches are
coming down too I think they are a
little bit the luxury luxury stuff's
going down right uh but people are still
buying and selling like crazy like
people are trying to get me into that
instead watches yeah Rox you should get
into watches probably have to get a gun
huh did it yeah but and it I kind of
want to just cuz it takes less space
dude I had a [__] date just it's not
even anything special right and it was
like 4 years old and I went to to the
jewelry shop and I was like hey how much
would you take this for or like 7,300
I'm like oh God I got it for like 68 and
I'm like from the factory that made it
at night at night at the same one and
don't don't open it just just just clean
it don't change your battery don't
change your battery there's no battery
there's no battery I mean there's no
batteries I can buy luxury goods we
basically for free and make more money
on it why not yeah that's what I did
with shoes yeah I bought all the stuff
that I wanted wore it for a little bit
and then I'm like how do you not scuff
your [__] I have well I use like all the
sprays and all that stuff it just kind
of got annoying after a while cuz I have
to like watch where I step cuz some of
them they have like that bottom that the
plastic thing you put on the bottom
right yeah I don't do that cuz it feels
weird have you seen Patrick mahomes's
shoe collection I have not it's [__]
crazy dude he has like every single Sho
except for the air
obvious I'm glad that you know the name
though that like is a little bit like
saying would wouldn't need that one like
you're a real friend
though